in 2019 humanity received a warning 30
of the world's leading scientists
released the results of a massive
three-year study into global agriculture
and declared that meat production is
destroying our planet and jeopardizing
global health one of the study's authors
explained that humanity now poses a
threat to the stability of the planet
this requires nothing less than a new
global agricultural revolution as
somebody who spent the last two decades
advocating a shift away from industrial
meat production I wanted to believe that
this clarion call was going to make a
difference the thing is I've seen this
sort of thing again and again and again
for decades
here's 2018 from the journal Nature 2017
from bioscience journal 2016 from the
National Academy of Sciences the main
point of these studies tends to be
climate change but antibiotic resistance
represents just as big of a threat we
are feeding massive doses of antibiotics
to farm animals these antibiotics are
then mutating into superbugs that
threaten to render antibiotics obsolete
within all of our lifetimes you want to
scare Google the end of working
antibiotics I'm gonna get one thing out
of the way I am NOT here to tell anybody
what to eat individual action is great
but antibiotic resistance and climate
change they require more besides
convincing the world to eat less meat
hasn't worked for 50 years
environmentalists global health experts
and animal activists have been begging
the public to eat less meat and yet per
capita meat consumption is as high as
it's been in recorded history the
average North American last year ate
more than 200 pounds of meat and I
didn't eat any which means somebody out
there ate 400 pounds of meat
on our current trajectory we're going to
need to be producing 70 to 100 percent
more meat by 2050 this requires a global
solution what we need to do is we need
to produce the meat that people love but
we need to produce it in a whole new way
I've got a couple of ideas idea number
one let's grow meat from plants instead
of growing plants feeding them to
animals and all of that inefficiency
let's grow those plants let's biomimic
meet with them let's make plant-based
meat idea number two for actual animal
meat let's grow it directly from cells
instead of growing live animals let's
grow the cells directly take six weeks
to grow a chicken to Solara wait grow
the cells directly you can get that same
growth in six days this is what that
looks like at scale it's your friendly
neighborhood meat brewery I want to make
two points about this the first one is
we believe we can do it in recent years
some companies have been producing meat
from plants that consumers cannot
distinguish from actual animal meat and
there are now dozens of companies
growing actual animal meat directly from
cells this plant based in cell based
meat gives consumers everything that
they love about me the taste the texture
and so on but with no need for
antibiotics and with a fraction of the
adverse impact on the climate and
because these two technologies are so
much more efficient at production scale
these products will be cheaper but one
quick point about that it's not going to
be easy
these plant-based companies have spent
small fortunes on their burgers and cell
based meat has not yet been
commercialized at all so we're going to
need all hands on deck to make these the
global meat industry for starters we
need the present meat industry we don't
want to disrupt the meat industry we
want to transform it
we need their economies of scale their
global supply chain their marketing
expertise and their massive consumer
base we also need governments
governments spend tens of billions of
dollars every single
year on research and development focused
on global health and the environment
they should be putting some of that
money into optimizing and perfecting the
production of plant-based and cell based
meat look tens of thousands of people
died from antibiotic resistant superbugs
in North America just last year by 2050
that number is going to be 10 million
per year globally and climate change
represents an existential threat to huge
portions of our global family including
some of the poorest people on the face
of the planet
climate change antibiotic resistance
these are global emergencies meat
production is exacerbating these
emergencies on a global scale but we are
not going to decrease meat consumption
unless we give consumers alternatives
that cost the same or less and that
tastes the same or better we have the
solution
let's make meat from plants let's grow
it directly from cells it's past time
that we mobilize the resources that are
necessary to create the next global
agricultural revolution thank you
[Applause]
[Music]